so good afternoon everybody and welcome
to the Thursday December 6 2018 session
in our series on AI and smart physical
systems
I'm Richard Dasher I direct the u.s.
Asia Technology Management Center at
Stanford and we're very happy to welcome
everyone here thanks to our member
companies specifically Bridgestone
Corporation and Kawasaki Heavy
Industries brilliant hope incorporated
meet cebiche Research Institute and it's
an icon University we will have some
refreshments afterward and we hope that
you'll stay afterward and talk to each
other and get to know everybody a little
bit better today for the final session
in our series I'm very happy to be able
to welcome Jim Adler who is the managing
director and founder of Toyota AI
Ventures
he's also an executive advisor at the
Toyota Research Institute so Jim started
out Toyota AI ventures in the middle of
2017 after TR I had been going on for
about a year and a half before the AI
Bichir started Jim was the vice
president of data and business
development for Toyota Research
Institute before that Jim was the vice
president of products and marketing at
Mehta nautics which is a big data
analytic start up with that received
Sequoia funding and workday which was
acquired by Microsoft before that Jim
was vice president of data systems and
the chief privacy officer at in Telus
which was acquired by hig Capital Jim
also founded vote here which is a
pioneering company in cryptographic
secure and secret online voting for
public elections that received funding
from Cisco Systems and HP he started his
career as a rocket engineer at Lockheed
Martin and I'm really delighted that Jim
can come and talk to us informally about
how sees he sees the landscape for AI
developing across Asia I'd like to start
off though with asking
here to kind of put together your story
a little bit and tell us how one leads
to the next tell us about your
background and also a little bit more
about what the adventures are doing sure
well first thank you for having me
especially the last at least seminar of
the of the quarter I really appreciate
it clearly from that introduction I can
hold a job or a boss which is somewhat
true I'm an electrical engineer by
training I love systems both physical
and information and business systems and
my career is that's sort of the through
line of my career I came out of school
launched rockets for the first half
dozen years of my career loved it
intensely is a course it's so exciting
for a kid coming out at a school to sit
at the bottom of a 300-foot booster and
have a billion dollars of payload at the
top of it and have a general ask you are
you ready are you ready to go and you
know what what do I know I'm 26 years
old
yes sir is really all I can mutter at
the time but I really obstruct
sought some entrepreneurial pursuits
which if you have listened to that
career it was really about a startup and
then exiting either successfully or not
and then resting and then startup and
resting and started interesting cuz
startups are tough and they're
emotionally draining but they're
wonderful and some of the best journeys
and rewarding times of my life has been
in the cauldron of a start-up and when
we sold the last company to Microsoft it
was my time to rest so one of the
cofounders of the of meta knotek's went
to school here at Stanford with the
chief technology officer of Toto
Research Institute James Kufner and
since metadox was sold to Microsoft of
course Microsoft wanted to it was a
relatively small company where we had
just raised a Series A we're about to
raise a B they wanted to move us back to
Seattle but I had to spend 20 years
raising our kids in Seattle and the deal
I cut with my wife Robin who's here
actually today is and all successful
marriages by the way I'll give you a
marriage tip periodic renegotiation of
the terms of the marriage and so the the
negotiation we struck was she wanted to
get out of the rain and I wanted to do
another startup so we moved to the
Silicon Valley here and I got to do my
startup she got out of the rain but who
buys us Microsoft who wants to move us
right back to the rain so she was not
having that and and luckily the
co-founder of Mehta notic said you got
to meet James and I met James and Gill
Pratt who runs the Tory Research
Institute and just fell in love with the
personnel and the and the vision and the
mission and really what is what it what
Toyota's facing right now in the auto
industry generally this level of
disruption is really unprecedented and
and I not a motive which was I know
we're going to talk about more and so I
was I was brought in to run the data and
cloud team because I had done that in
intelligence and and worked deeply with
big data systems at meta knotek's so I
said sure I know how to build a data
science cloud team I'll certainly do
that about for the first year and a half
but Twitter research had this little
kitty of money to do investments and and
they were starting to do them and I
because I can't keep my mouth shut I
really was a little bit critical of how
they were doing them because I had taken
corporate investment in my in my
entrepreneurial past and I had really
good corporate investors and I had
really terrible corporate investors and
I really did not want twitter to be a
terrible corporate investor and so I
made my opinions known to Gill and James
and the team and and Gill in his the way
he the reason he's an amazing leader he
said okay smart guy go fix it and so I
wrote a manifesto of what I think was
important for a venture capital fund to
be a separate subsidiary to have
financial incentives that align with the
entrepreneurs and the co-investors to
have a clear investment thesis to treat
founders and founding teams as customers
and recognize that financial return
precede strategic return for corporate
investing usually corporates get it the
wrong way they try to extract the
strategic value before the company is
viable and successful and I that is a
recipe for disaster
so they indulged the prescription and
the structure of this fund it's a
hundred million dollar fund it's focused
on seed and early-stage investments in
AI data cloud autonomous mobility and
robotics and we have a five member board
we're kind of built for speed one of the
one of the most important things I
imposed or impressed upon Toyota was we
need to run at the clock speed of
startups we can't expect startups turn
at the clock speed of Toyota and the
beautiful part of that was the
leadership of Toyota all the way up to a
pio Toyota totally gets that and they
were completely supportive of that so we
set up a five-member board - there's
seven executive vice presidents at
Toyota two of them are on my board Gill
Pratt and Toma Yama son and myself and
outside board member and an another t.ri
executive Kelly K and we moved really
quickly we've since as Richard said July
2017 we've done 17 deals we've announced
their teen of them we're running at
about a deal a month roughly and we're
getting into some really exciting
opportunities so to follow up the the
fun the hundred million is all Toyota
money right it's yet so it's an LP
structure yeah and and effectively a
single LP okay but are you co investing
most of the time
yeah we've we leave deals we've led a
couple deals we follow we tend to follow
more than lead or your average check
size is two million bucks we've gone as
high as eight we've gone as low as 250 K
so pretty wide variance but kind of a
sweet spot is back okay
I really like your point about saying
that financial return has to pre precede
strategic return but surely when you're
looking at investments you're
considering the strategic possibilities
at the same time right yes and I think
the well the thesis is informed
strategically right that's why we're
investing in these areas but there
always is this conversation at the board
level at the investment committee level
that every time we do a deal the
question always is well how's this
retreat for Toyota and we usually have
that wrestle wrestling match inside the
investment committee meeting which I
think is the right place to happen if
you don't have it there you end up
having it in the board room of the
startup which is the worst place to have
it or by coercing or influencing the
founding team to do what you want that
never is good startups are incredibly
delicate and incredibly powerful but in
the early stages they need to be treated
with a measure of distance and so
especially from someone like Toyota any
or any big company really so yes we we
decide that that strategic those
strategic contours really in the
investment committee meeting so things
are moving so rapidly and kind of I'd
say in an uncertain direction in
industries like the automotive industry
are you doing how do you how do you do
the process for mapping out strategic
space and kind of looking at new areas
to invest in yeah well I think one of
the advantages we have is that because
we're a subsidiary of Toyota Research
Institute we have some of the best
researchers and engineers in robotics
and autonomy right next to us and so we
do get this osmotic feed of where the
problems are where the opportunities
might lie there at the cutting edge the
bleeding edge of a lot of these
innovations if you if you think about
the autonomy stack it kind of breaks
into three general areas there's
perception which is sensors and what is
the world and then prediction what will
the world be
and then finally planning what will I do
in the world
and that applies to a predictive
analytic system for business process all
the way to a physical system like a car
and then underneath though that that
stack that layered stack is tools
compute edge cloud all the
infrastructure to execute those layers
of the stack so right now are you seeing
things in one of those layers as being
more interesting than others or equal oh
yeah no no they're not even wish it was
that easy we do one of the things that
we think that perception is a lot of the
we think that is soon to be a solved
problem the the theoretical
underpinnings have by and large been
solved now you have to of course execute
and productize and package and row and
and ride that that cost efficiency
curved down planning also is is a little
bit more difficult but we see
innovations there deal in the oh the
perceptions not yeah when you say it's
about to be solved lidar is still kind
of you know developing all right yes so
in terms of you're looking on of say
seven or eight your timeline or what
kind of a timeline are you looking yeah
well I think the question is the the
product ization of that layer is
happening now so will it be just lidar
will it be lidar will it be radar will
it be cameras will it be some
interesting new sensor that's all the
input to this fusion layer which will
actually detect and parse the
environment for these sensors okay so I
mean that part from a research
perspective I think it's under at least
the problems are not there know right
now because if you look at the
prediction layer I don't think we even
have scratched the surface and that that
is where especially on roads because
there's not just
other robotic cars on the road there's
human driven cars and pedestrians and
bicyclists and it's a social ballet of a
sort of social contract of what
everyone's allowed to do and should do
and does do and all of that also is
locally defined so what works in Palo
Alto may not work in New York City may
not work in Riyadh may not work in Tokyo
may not work in Shenzhen so how do how
do we teach these machines to interact
with humans yeah really difficult so in
that regard of are you seeing more of
the weight going into the car or more of
the weight going into say intelligent
transportation systems the
infrastructure I so if your question is
like the vehicle the infrastructure the
kind of thing I think that we as an
automaker we see a lot going through the
car I think that's something that we can
control and we have influence over it's
not to say that certain governments and
public policy groups will put more
infrastructure and make our problem
easier we're just now relying on that
yeah so with regard to any of these
areas and I don't ask for information
that's still confidential but other new
developments that you think are really
kind of neat yeah every day every day
there's so much going on in this not
just at Toyota but across that's why
we're investing because there's so much
innovation happening and it's being
fueled by tremendous influx influx of
venture capital both from institutions
and corporates and I mean we just made
an investment in this company perceptive
automata around prediction and they are
actually using psychoanalytic models
sociographic models to model what goes
on on the road and it's so deceptively
difficult because when you're in a car
you do project your mentality into every
they're round you my favorite example is
a unprotected left turn if you know an
unprotected left turn is when you need
to make a left turn and there's no stop
sign there's no there there's no light
you have to cross a lane of traffic and
then someone's got to let you in very
difficult my personal rule of thumb is
always jump in front of a car that's
nicer than yours and to let you in hard
when you're driving Alexis though but
yeah and I do appreciate what you say
because in some parts of Asia it's the
car that's one centimetre ahead has the
right-of-way that's right that's right
and it's and it is really this social
contract of how you negotiate all this
and how do we teach machines to do that
it's I think we're just getting started
I remember Gill Pratt had said one at
one point to a team meeting he said
what's so fascinating about this field
is that yes where we're teaching these
machines but we're gonna learn as much
about ourselves as we teach these
machines and that is I think so true in
in in some very distinct ways like our
own prior experience is how we
understand the world and what you teach
a machine is how they are going to see
the world there's a sense that machines
are perfect and neutral they are not
they're just like us they're a subject
of a product of their experience and
they have biases so in that regard what
would you say is kind of the most
difficult steps between now and a world
in which autonomous vehicles are mixed
with people driving their own cars well
I think I think the challenge with with
mobility is is first safety and and how
how safe does it need to be how did the
safety these systems need to be to be
accepted it's a really difficult
question and one that technologists and
companies cannot solve alone it would
require a societal conversation to
really answer that question I mean
40,000 people die in the United State
from car crashes every year you know if
autonomous driving dropped that by half
would that be enough it may not be
because we are very intolerant to
machines making mistakes that hurt us
we're very tolerant of people hurting us
because I think were empathetically put
ourselves in the position of the person
and say oh I could have made that
mistake so we're much more empathetic to
people than we are to machines so these
machines are gonna have to be much much
better you know than human drivers for
us to accept them and we are going
through that process now any idea about
timing yeah it's because it's a societal
policy question I don't really I don't
really know I do know that there's
different approaches to the problem yeah
so let me come at it from that angle
since I can't predict what governments
will do if you look at some of the
larger autonomy efforts their effort
their focus is to drive as many miles as
they can on as many roads and as many
weather conditions as possible and then
one day flip the switch and say we're
ready
I think a year two ago Google way Moe
said hey we did it we crossed a million
miles or maybe it was three million
miles a couple years ago and then
recently was 10 million miles
well how many miles is enough ran says
it's eight billion miles we have a
company called main mobility that is
driving fixed routes in certain urban
areas and they're operating design
domain they're ODB is very narrow so
they've really constrained the problem
to being so simple that they can drive
it autonomously or soon will and they
drive the same route 200 times a day so
they they see everything they need to
see on that on that route they see it in
all
there they see it in all lighting
conditions they see it with construction
they understand all the pedestrians and
bicyclists so they could really deeply
manage the safety requirements yeah they
can even put to your point Richard about
infrastructure they can't even put
sensors at intersections because they
drive the route a couple hundred times a
day so they can put a light R or a
camera where they need it you know look
around the corner yeah so I think that's
a much more viable approach to growing
this set of operational design domains
operating design domains instead of
trying to boil the ocean and then just
one day say it's ready I think that's a
viable so you're going back and forth to
Japan a lot
are you sourcing your deals from Asia as
well as from the US or most of them
coming from Silicon Valley or how what
one would you say about that so far it's
been Silicon Valley Boston we have a
deal in Montana some great light our
guys up there we have a deal in London
and in Tel Aviv Israel okay
we haven't done a deal yet in Japan we
are partnered with the my creation fund
out of Tokyo and so if we've Cohen
vested with them on several deals okay
Toyota's a limited partner in that month
so we get some collaboration through
through that vehicle so Mirai how many
investments would you say you're through
them I think we've done four or five I
think okay okay so are you looking
around at the landscape in Asia we are
developing
yeah we are of course China is is
undeniable and and is not to be ignored
for reasons we can talk about I think
Japan is beginning to really wake up to
the opportunity you know is the third
largest economy in the world they have a
role to play great universities happen
to have one of the best car makers right
there in their backyard
and and so I think Japan will definitely
be it will be growing for you know in
this face now you mentioned China and
said we can talk about it I was really
impressed how many autonomous vehicle
companies there are in China yeah are
you looking at that landscape it looks
really hot it almost looks like it's too
hot it's very hot and very expensive
there's a tremendous amount of venture
capital chasing too few deals so it's
all supply and demand and and the prices
are sky high okay so but with what 1.4
billion people and second largest
economy in the world
I don't think China can be ignored of
course and I also think that what the
u.s. benefited from with the auto
industry where we the u.s. automated ger
is really just able to serve their local
markets in the early days China can just
serve their local market and they'll
just be fine make it so that and they
can mature in their market and then
export and and do more as they mature
and I think that's an undeniable
advantage just like it was for the US
one of the points that's come up several
times when we've had content about China
in this area is sort of the attitudes
and how they're reflected in regulation
and that people are actually more
accepting of AI solutions in China than
they are here here you suddenly get
people worried about privacy you get
people worried about you know individual
empowerment and that's not part of the
discussion in China are you seeing that
kind of cultural difference is something
that will really be an important impact
and have an important impact in the way
the business sector develops definitely
I spend obviously a lot of time in Japan
and if you look at just adoption of
robots in Japan they're welcomed and
here we our uncanny valley is very wide
here in the United States and in Japan
it's relatively narrow
and I think one of the reasons why
Toyota is such an amazing automakers
Toyota understands how empowering an
object can be for people even if it's
not anthropomorphic I mean when you hit
the accelerator in a car you just get
this rush of autonomy and agency and
Toyota really understands that and I
think that transfers to other objects
other robots that there there there is a
connection that we humans have to things
in our world and I think a big mistake
that many roboticists make is that they
try to construct a robot that looks like
a person mm-hmm and we have an
investment in a company out of Israel
that called leq and it doesn't look like
a person at all it's a social companion
for older adults we know that especially
in Japan the aging Society is a huge
problem there the agent dependency ratio
is getting you know worse and worse it's
gonna be five there's gonna be for
retirees to every five non retirees in
about 40 years I think maybe 60 years
four to five and so you can't
institutionalize all these people yeah
they need to they need we all you know
would like to age in place and I think
if you look at this robot it just looks
like a smart lamp all right I just got
no wise has a light but it but it does
articulate and it doesn't motivate an
object and it's a it's it's getting
amazing reviews because it's not trying
to do too much of a card does something
very narrow but very well and we have
affection for it so the example of this
company indicates that you're investing
outside the automobile space definitely
so you're looking at service robots and
other kind of physical systems too
that's right we don't know what's next
for Toyota part of the mission is Toyota
is a top 10 consumer brand in the world
the best design and manufacturer
automaker in the world but what's next
we don't know there's a quite a bit of
disruption hitting the auto industry and
really an autonomous vehicle is just a
really big wheeled robot so this is one
of the hardest things for any large
company when you're looking at new
opportunities and trying to figure out
how you might start a new business line
or whatever can you say anything about
your discussions with the Toyota
executives and have you seen things that
you've talked about wind up showing up
in strategic plans or anything so far
well I think that I do a lot I think
that like all large companies that are
going through an era of disruption as
clay Christensen from Harvard Business
School's taught us innovators have a
dilemma how do they jump from the limits
that they've hit in their market success
to the next era of their market success
we I often give the example of Kodak
where in the 70s they their market cap
was about 30 billion dollars they
invented digital photography 20 years
later Facebook and an Apple created
about a trillion dollars of market cap
primarily on the backs of digital
photography the phone may takes the
pictures and Facebook distributes them
those are the killer apps and meanwhile
Kodak filed bankruptcy and is now worth
about 150 million dollars down from 30
billion how did Kodak miss digital
photography it's not that they weren't
smart they were just focused on their
business and their business was film and
they couldn't see past film actually
that's a really interesting case study
because at the same time Fuji film in
Japan really started investing in
biotech mm-hmm and is really almost more
of a biotech company now being that all
right
certainly camera film is not much for
exactly and I think that's the challenge
for automotive is you know it is
when you see this high-tech insurgency
coming how do you become high tech
before high tech becomes automotive and
you're seeing this now that the
insurgents are Google and Apple and
Amazon and Tesla and Nvidia Intel these
are the companies that are coming to
automotive and what is the auto
automotive industries response well the
reason we created this fund is to tap
into that disruption kind of understand
it a little better and what can we learn
from it
startups are experiments in the
marketplace and we want to run these
experiments we want these companies to
be successful we may want to at some
point acquire some of the capabilities
of these companies after they've been
appropriately de-risked and pay top
dollar to pay market prices for them
cisco has been running this playbook for
30 years and I think it works it helps
you disrupt yourself before you get
disrupted so kind of my last question
before we open things up to the audience
is in this era of disruption and
therefore of great uncertainty would you
have recommendations for how a company
can best cope and also how individuals
like students can best cope yeah sure
so it depends welcome from a company
perspective I'll get personal from a
company perspective a company evolves by
adopting new capabilities whether
they're built or bought and those new
capabilities open up new opportunities
to satisfy new customers and deliver
value to customers and so companies need
to figure this out so now if you have
you know Marc Andreessen Andreessen
famously said right 2011 software is
eating the world yes now cars are on the
menu and those companies that likely
will succeed will be the ones that are
more data native and software native so
how does a Toyota become more data
native and it's a cultural thing so data
native as opposed to data driven I'm
curious about your choice of words there
yeah because I think data driven means
using data to inform your business data
native means you just think in data you
the best example I have is when I first
that becomes the unit of values that's
right that's right and it's an app it's
a balance sheet asset so when I first
came to Toyota I was very excited cuz I
was a data guy and I thought wow Toyota
market leader must have a ton of data
and it took me about three months of
asking around where's the data I know we
have the date and you know folks in the
cover like what do you mean what data
what are you talking about data like
come on your Toyota there must be tons
of data and sure enough took me three or
four months and you know in a bunker
under Nagoya I found the mother lode of
data and and it was you know collected
over decades and it's not that anyone's
trying to hide anything
it's just they didn't realize that this
data was an asset it was great dash cam
data a lot of it was labeled and it was
it was an asset that could be used to
train our machine learning models now of
course they're not thinking that way
because they've been using it as test
data to make verified Wells little lot
of it was type of machine learning
models was not a conservative exactly
why you could have you could repurpose
it and the point is this is an asset and
so when your data native you think about
your data assets as balance sheet value
and and and that's the difference so
that's likely to continue yeah and I
think and then you have to build the
culture around this data Nativity is
about culture it's about having data
scientists data engineers business
people articulate and live within this
data world and reward that ring culture
as well what you reward if you only
reward the hardware engineers you're
going to get a hardware company right if
you reward data
facility and capability well then you're
going to get a data company and so
that's really what the challenge is for
this transition for the seventies so
that's what the company side
individually how do how do you deal with
this kind of yeah total disruption yeah
well so I'm sure you know you've read
the KY Fuli book I'm reading it now
and I find it really interesting that it
there's like he thinks about this and at
least two axes the creativity axes and
and and the compassion axis and and
we're just fate we're just beginning to
figure this out I don't think those are
the only two axes and so you're I come
from a line of physicians I broke my
grandfather and my father's heart by not
becoming a physician when I said I was
my dad I was gonna become an engineer he
thought I was going to drive a train it
wasn't quite sure what an engineer was
but I took one really important lesson
from both of them is that you're a
student your whole life and things are
going to change rapidly and in order to
be a creative force as high Fuli talks
about and or in order to be a creative
force and a humanitarian you have to
have that sensitivity and that
willingness to change and be creative
your whole career and so learn I mean I
learned a lot in college but the most
important thing I learned was how to
learn and and and where to pick up
wisdom and yeah and I've been doing it
that's why I can't hold a job because I
get interested in a new thing and I just
I want to pour myself into it I mean
people say Jim house how are you at weiu
at Toyota you're in a start-up guy I'm
finding Twitter to be a startup I mean
they are going through this transition
and I find incredibly invigorating for
some weird reason and it's like this you
know n dimensional chess of how do you
get this company to not become a kodak
well you're also a the you know the
intersection point of one of the most
interesting sides of innovation right
now that's right which is where the big
company is trying to get information for
outside knowledge from outside trying to
come up with new partnerships trying to
do open innovation that's right
I think and I and so let me be more
specific for what can what can you do
being a bit of a polymath is really
helpful you know understand some
technology you got to be able to have
skills right whether whether it's
mathematical skills software skills
writing skills communication those are
those are so important to hone
maniacally because at the end of the day
that's what you bring to the party
that's what you bring to the table but
then everyone is part of a team right
there's there's no I hate cultures that
are pardon the the gender specificity
but cowboy cultures right the hero
culture hero cultures are the worst
because you reward someone solving a
problem that often they created right I
call it the the the fight the arsonist
firefighter right and and and what you
want is a team you want you don't want
heroes you don't want cowboys you want a
team that communicates well that
understands the positions I when I
relate a team I never talk about family
most families are dysfunctional sound
like we're not a family we're a team
right and and everyone has a position
and we are trying to score points
whatever the game is and we all have a
position and we all stumble and we we
don't we can't play at always at 150% we
and and that's okay but we all have to
rely on each other and and I think
that's a much better model to deal with
the influx of entropy and change and
competition in order to be successful
yeah that's such an interesting point I
can't let it go so I do think that there
is this kind of archetype behind
business in
Asia that it's basically an extension of
the Confucian family and when we talk
about team I'm curious if our ideas of
team really are the same ideas of team
that Asian people would come up with
sewing point when you say team what kind
of sport just is in the back of your
mind well I I grew up so in nineteen I'm
gonna date myself so I grew up in Miami
Florida so you know the Miami Dolphins
had their perfect season and think in 72
73 so I'm a football fan for it forever
yeah and so I studied Vince Lombardi and
the great coaches and so I think about
it that way that everyone works seven
days a week we do work hard but there is
game day and and but I think it
translates to you know any team sport
for sure yeah and even individual sports
I think I think it's not the interesting
thing about it and I've looked at this
as football has great indeterminacy once
the play starts right and you really
don't know what's going to happen and
people may have to do something totally
different than their usual position not
almost never happens in baseball that's
right you know the ball is sit down the
first place line you know where the
second baseman is going to go that's
right and that's I think fundamental to
our sense of how to deal with
uncertainty that's a great point and I I
didn't think of that would think about
it that way which is why I love football
and I know you know I'm not a huge
baseball fan but I come from a long line
of baseball fans but for the Europeans
in the audience and it's let me point
out that soccer soccer even more amazing
that's right these people know where
each other are without looking that's
right that's right and actually price
soccer is a better example because it's
continuous yeah and you have positions
it's there's these exogenous events that
kind of impose themselves and that you
have to deal with and you have to pull
together and I love I love both those
dynamics well having gotten this
arguably kind of far away from
you
[Applause]